it's yeah I want I want like I hope it
like I don't know I feel like we need to
start not being so angry at things I I
sit on the internet sometimes and I'm
just like [ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] thank you and would
people can go on I can't really go on
every morning I check Instagram and I
wake up with that with resentment
jealousy yeah you gotta take gets really
unhealthy it is I do that I do that a
lot too I definitely think that I'm
trying to put my phone down way more in
this book I read oh wait go ahead go
ahead yeah I get I mean I get I don't
get jealous of other DJs but I think
it's just like that you just start
things start pissing you off you read
people's captions like [ __ ] you dude
mean that [ __ ] yeah yeah get real
philosophical yeah they are absolutely
like dude your caption doesn't match who
you are man that's another thing it's
like you know somebody right I know some
comedians well and then they try to put
up this thing that they're nice or
they're adventurous or that you know I
mean they they're interesting right and
I'm like no you're a dull piece of [ __ ]
and put that out there because you don't
do that you're on a mountain who brought
you there
you didn't bring yourself there you have
some [ __ ] girl woman just to the
arrived Bam Bam rentin ranting I'm
ranting okay silly whatever like even me
like even me I do it and I am at myself
when I put that [ __ ] photo later we
all get with a copy no don't worry from
getting caught up there cuz when you
start seeing then you're like like cuz
you think you have to play the game of
course and you know like back then this
book I read explains it perfectly it's
like when you're a farmer way back when
before social media and you're just
having a shitty day plowing you say this
I'm having a shitty day I don't feel
good
five minutes later you're like alright
got to keep moving now when you're
having a shitty day you look on internet
and everyone is having a grand old life
and so that makes you instead of feeling
shitty for five minutes you're gonna
feel shitty for far longer time because
you're using that like upward comparison
to basically you know
keep you down but then what is it about
me that wants to make other people feel
shitty it's that it's that you got
shitty feels good it feels good like
when I did that movie when I did that
with me when I did that movie keep up
with the Joneses right yeah and I'm like
I'm you know I'm doing the scene with
John Hammonds that guy for now that's
right I don't yeah I know that but I
don't know we're not besties yeah yeah
but yeah you got to make it seem like
you are right yeah so one day you know
one day we were outside and and we I was
smoking and John goes give me one of
those him and then Zack just happened to
be in the area and he sat with us so in
my head here's the photo-op you know I
don't generally do this but seems like a
photo op opportunity like a photo
opportunity Gilbert [ __ ] you you said
opportunity so I did I took the photo
and immediately in my head for the next
hour you know because I know that if I
put this on it's gonna make so-and-so
so-and-so and so-and-so so irritated
yeah because they're not doing anything
[Music]